I don't think there's any risk of there
being some instantaneous singularity in
which computers are suddenly going to
take over do I think that machines that
student master makers know do I think
that's somebody cared yeah you know that
machines can do everything the brains
can do cuz the brain is a machine
the question is will machines soon match
their makers or is it science fiction
heightened and will a real a I remain
elusive because I have to me but
misunderstood the nature both of our
forties and what machines are so to help
us discuss this topics we have on my
right Hillary Lawson Hillary is a non
realist philosopher Kay Devlin senior
lecturer at Goldsmiths Department of
computing and she works in the fields of
human-computer interaction and
artificial intelligence and David
Chalmers charmers sorry formulator of
the hard problem of consciousness which
there everybody talked about for decades
and still do philosopher of mind is the
author of the singularity and Hillary
would you would you start us off please
we've some we've always been rather over
impressed with what computers can do
from you know the cracking of the ending
the codes to beating us at chess and as
a result we somehow imagine that they're
going to the takeover or all of the
things that we can do which I'd say I go
to are give us an illusion we just have
to remind ourselves of what they sailed
to do I mean 50 years ago in the film
2001 we have a character of how he was
running the ship and took over the ship
and malevolently operated against humans
and of course we are nowhere near a
computer being able to do that and we've
long since passed 2001 so computers have
not lived up to what we thought they
they might do and more than that they're
not even able to do the sort of things
that a two-year-old child we take for
granted could do so no computer can
identify any object it that is in the
world the only way we've been able to
get computers to identify objects is to
tell them that they're choosing between
say five objects I could cut them a
saucer and a mug or whatever and they're
presented in just the right distance
from the camera and separated in a
reasonable fashion and then it can just
about distinguish the cut from the
saucer but you actually put it in a
real-world situation our computers not
able to identify it and if we can't
identify computers can't identify the
objects or objects in the world then how
could they possibly make any judgments
about how to interact and and and make
judgments about what to do I think
underlying that there is a problem that
computer scientists have adopted the
same sort of overall common sense
framework that most of us are jobs which
is that we imagine that the world is
already divided into things
and all that we are engaged in doing is
identifying those things so I don't
think that is what's going on I think we
hold the world as things so our senses
are not mirrors to the world
show us what the world is what they do
is they respond the world a course or a
sausage they're like flags in the wind
or bells in the wind we have to hold the
world as things and not the same thing
as what's out there we have to hold me
there as things in order to be able to
intervene so I think that computer
science would have to do exactly the
same thing now it has done so to some
degree so Igor exam or 30 years ago
developed a computer program which was
able to identify different faces and
rather remarkably could could could
distinguish between a thousand faces
rather better than than humans could do
but he didn't do this by identifying the
same things that we do like the eyes and
the nose and the mouth
he just said is this the same image as
the one that I've seen previously if it
was the same it would say call that a
and if it was not the same it would call
it be and it would gradually increase
the number until it has a sense of all
of the different faces so I think we
could build an intelligent machine that
would make its own categories in its own
distinctions and be able indeed
potentially to be able to intervene but
if we did such a thing and it was born
in Florida it would be a lot worse than
the two-year-old baby would have it
wouldn't have the advantages of a couple
of million years of evolution and all of
the advantages we've got in creating our
closures and we would then have to train
it so I don't think there's any risk of
there being some frightening of
instantaneous singularity in which
computers are suddenly going to take
over we're going to have to train them
and it would take an immensely long time
for us first of all to develop machine
which will do that and then for us to be
able to train it and get it to a state
where it could intervene sensibly
do I think that machines will soon match
their makers no do I think that somebody
could yeah
and I think there's a couple of things
you mentioned at the start about Alan
Turing sang Morgan soon whatever it was
30 50 years we're gonna have fun when he
wrote his paper I'm sad yes we're gonna
have this terrain in the same paper also
devised a task for extrasensory
perception no I'm not denigrating
sharing in the slightest but just that's
not come upon either so I think we feel
you know that the man was a genius at
the start of a computing revolution um
the reason I think I mean it's its
reasons that we're all probably gonna
have in common as to why we think that's
not gonna happen soon where we expect
that if a machine was to match its
makers we would wanted to have some kind
of awareness some kind of sentience that
rivals are as though it's on a par with
ours and there are different approaches
to that NII there is the approach where
we have we have somehow replicated the
human brain and there are projects where
people are trying to do this to trying
to model the human brain I don't think
that's particularly effective way of
doing it the other one is to have
human-like computing where we have
machines that react in the same way that
we might expect they behave like a human
but there's other stuff going behind the
scenes like Hillary says it can identify
things in a different way now the bit
that I disagree with Hillary is about
the training because I think if we
create a machine that is that does have
this level of intelligence there's no
reason why it has to go through a
training series that will last a long
time this could be something that very
rapidly the technology develops and
learns I think at the moment technology
computers robotics or listen to stuff
they were designed for very individual
narrow tasks so it also go recently
alphago bait the champion go player we
didn't think that would happen for at
least on the ten years that was that was
a grind breaking thing for a computer to
treat a go player the problem with that
is alphago is rubbish at pictionary
right you don't want to they don't like
up against it you know they won't
against you um we could train a robot to
be really good at pictionary
okay not that's doable under people
working on all sides of
Computers creating art computers that
are Commission's that are companions to
us we have Carol butts out there right
now looking after people people for
attachments with him but they're all for
very specific and narrow tasks so I
think that while some day given the
technology and the time you can say this
might pretty much any computational
challenge given the right technology
given it enough time given some monkeys
typing Shakespeare on series of infinite
typewriters we could we could come up
with this we could solve this problem
but right now it's not gonna happen
anytime soon I think there's things we
have to worry about right now with
artificial intelligence are much more
precise things things that the influence
that they're having on the world and on
society but one of those things you know
those things are not a machine
uprising I don't think
so topic then is what machines can't do
and I guess the thought is to contrast
what machines can't do with what we can
or can't do with our with our human
brains my thought is maybe there are
some things that brains can do that
machines can't do well nobody put it
that way I think there's something
something wrong with the framings we
know that machines can do everything
that brains can do why because the brain
is a machine the brain is itself a big
complicated machine with a whole bunch
of physical mechanisms interacting
producing producing behavior so I guess
the question really is something like
not what machines can't do but what our
social machines come to maybe artificial
machines will be limited or maybe well
computational machines can't do a
programmed machines can't do and the
thought is maybe there are things that
brains can do that programmed or
artificial machines can't too
you